durant toute ma vie les dix anneaux ont
rendu ma famille puissante
et si tu veux qu'ils appartiennent plus
tard tu dois me prouver que tu es assez
fort pour les mériter
tu es le produit de tous ceux qui t'ont
précédé
tu est l'héritier de ta famille tu est
amer et que ça te plaise ou pas
tu es aussi ton père
j'ai dit à mes hommes qu'il n'arriverait
pas te tuer même s'il essayait
heureux d'avoir eu raison
tu n'es qu'un criminel 1 tu as rien plus
ne me parlent jamais sur ce ton petit
j'ai voulu changer de nom
changer de vie
mais je ne pourrai jamais
échappé à son antre
mon fils
on ne peut pas fuir ton passé
c'est ce que tu voulais
tu peux t'en sortir
bien sûr tu
walcott